[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning it's
christmas eve and
millions of americans are waiting
anxiously to see if their gifts will be
delivered on time
new numbers show on-time delivery for
each of the three major u.s carriers
fedex ups and the postal service is more
than 93 percent
but they say due to overwhelming demand
more than one million orders may not get
to their destinations by christmas
errol burnett is outside a u.s postal
service hub in new york city and errol i
know yesterday
i saw a ups store on the upper east side
the line was wrapped all around the
corner what's it like there
oh yeah it's the same jamie busy busy
busy we're outside one of the most
frenetic distribution centers
in the country and today is really like
their super bowl
consider the challenges right now the
pandemic is ravaging the country vaccine
distribution is underway
and there are record online orders
taking place
so for them they're doing what they can
on what very well could be
the postal services most daunting
challenge ever
in a year unlike any other the race for
shippers to deliver packages to homes
and businesses nationwide is reaching
its pinnacle
everybody understands that their people
been doing a lot more online shopping
that the delivery system is flooded with
packages
the u.s postal service is getting hit
hard shipping millions more items a day
than average
partially due to shipping caps at ups
and fedex
in the first week of december
first-class on-time deliveries
fell to just 75 i'm worried about the us
coastal system i'm not sure what's going
on
hopefully it will improve and they'll
figure it out what is it like
to be a postal worker right now well
it's
it's daunting mark diminsteen is the
president of the american postal workers
union
representing a third of the more than
644 thousand
postal service employees in addition to
deliveries he says
more than 6 000 workers have tested
positive for covid
in just the last week with all of that
we're still out here like all other
essential workers
should people brace themselves and
expect that things may be a little late
this weekend i
i think in some situations people
uh will be disappointed that the gifts
through the post office and maybe some
other carriers do not make it
quite on time private carriers are also
overwhelmed
last week ups healthcare president wes
wheeler warned our chris van cleave
of potential holiday gift delays as the
covet 19 vaccine
rolled out across the country if it
comes down to it what gets priority
my christmas gifts or the vaccine the
vaccines will get
they'll get the first priority on the
aircraft first priority on
on the on the package car when it goes
to the final destination
if your package happens to be on that
same truck you're lucky
because it'll be in the first priority
package car going out from the
gateway some shoppers are choosing to
take matters into their own hands
but these long lines popping up in
shopping malls
as customers look to avoid any delays
some things you kind of want to get in
your hands and look at
and before you buy and you can't always
do that online
while others have been left without
answers this year it's been a disaster
the owners of gracie's doggy delights in
watertown wisconsin say
they fear they've lost customers because
of delays i don't know what's causing
the delays
i i know they're being you know they
have staffing issues i know they're
being
jammed up on a lot of people ordering
things but they had to know this was
coming
it sounds like you you're very
understanding that everyone's dealing
with this
and postal carriers are doing everything
they can but
there are hiccups along the way we just
hope that people
understand that's all we we know that
the the postal workers are working hard
we can see it in our own local carrier
spaces we get it i understand i'm not
putting this on anybody i just hope that
somebody understands
that on the other end that that we got
our stuff out and
and little patience will go a long way
breach now despite all of that there are
some companies
still offering same-day delivery on
millions of items
today for a price that is we're talking
amazon
target and walmart prepared to deliver
items that you may order here on
christmas eve
so if you've really procrastinated
you've got some last minute shopping to
do
and you really want to test your
patience and anxiety vlad
go for it errol barnett my man i got to
give you props for
maintaining that concentration during
your time with that noise that white
noise you're working
you're working well done errol barnett
thank you very much for that
it's been frustrating for me with this
delivery thing because yeah for the
first time ever
my wife and i decided to do personalized
christmas cards with like a little bit
because we got married
and you know we're always getting
everybody's always showing us their kids
and whatever and we did it this year and
they still have not come
we ordered them a month ago oh my gosh
sorry
i'm sure you're just happy to get gifts
at this point in time even if they are
last week i am
[Laughter]
you know what it'll be a wonderful new
year's edition to my mailbox when i get
your
gift coming it's in the mail vladimir
you just saw errol's report she doesn't
want us to say this she got me this
beautiful necklace i'm wearing merry
christmas and she got you some cuffs she
got me some amazing cufflinks
you guys are so good to me so i have the
best jacket you are the best
we love you very much merry christmas
all right errol thank you very much for
that